it's the most incredible thing to to
leave your home planet behind and to go
and you know look at the earth from
space and look back on this beautiful
planet we live on so fully
understandable
what impact would it have had on his
body i mean he is 90 bless
i mean you're going to have some
g-forces there with both the the launch
and the the re-entry although this is a
sub-orbital spacecraft so you're not
going up to the you know the full sort
of g-forces that we would experience on
re-entry from orbit but it would still
be a very exciting ride and for somebody
who's 90 years old all credit to him um
that's a that's an incredible thing to
put yourself through
so what would you say to somebody like
prince william who's being a bit
critical about all of this at the moment
what is the point of this is it just you
know billionaires playground
well there's a number of things when you
look at space and what we use space for
and why we use space you know space is
incredibly important to us right now
more than 50 percent of all of our
climate change data comes from
space-based assets it's part of our
critical national infrastructure
everybody is using space on a daily
basis probably without even knowing it
but we need to use space sustainably we
need to consider the environment
absolutely now when you look at rocket
fuel some of the best rocket fuel is
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen and
the by-product is water and actually
space
has a very very tiny impact on the
environment but that doesn't mean that
we can't be better at it i'm working
with companies at the moment such as sky
aurora which are developing eco scene
and environmentally friendly fuel you've
got companies like spacex who are
looking at sustainability reusability
bringing down the cost of access to
space but also cleaning up space and
making sure we protect it as an
environment for our future generations
that means bringing down the debris that
is already up there yeah i mean that was
part of the point he was making wasn't
it the world's greatest brain should
focus on saving the planet you're saying
they are they already are
well people are doing as much as they
can it obviously needs everybody to
collaborate and work together and it
needs everybody to be responsible it's
no point in just one small part of the
industry or one small nation doing this
this needs to be a global effort to make
sure that we protect space we use it
responsibly and we clean up the mess
that's already there and companies are
doing it it's very much the focus at the
moment um on the future it's very much
the focus at cop26 for space-based uh
companies as well is looking at how they
can be more environmental and how we can
clean up space
do you miss space
i miss it hugely
i mean it's not a day goes by when i
don't think about that view of earth
from space it is absolutely incredible
um yeah it's impossible to to go into
space and not for it to change your
perspective you see that thin strip of
earth's atmosphere it's only 16
kilometers thick and it makes you
realize that that is it that's what
differentiates us from you know mars or
venus and
it's incredibly important that we
protect that tiny strip of atmosphere
do you think you'll ever be able to go
back
i certainly hope so my classmates at the
european space agency are cycling
through second missions uh we have
tomorrow pesky from france up there
right now um and so myself and samantha
christopheretti andreas mogenson and
matthias marrow all in line hopefully
for missions coming up in the future
yeah in the meantime then you've been
keeping yourself busy by writing haven't
you
yeah well i've always wanted to get
involved in uh children's fiction books
um you know part of the mission was
having a big outreach program and i
think through fiction you can really
reach a young audience um and and have a
lot of fun at the same time so i've been
working with a brilliant writer steve
cole coleman between us we've come up
with a book swarm rising which is out
now and it's it's all about
alien intelligence coming to earth but
not perhaps as you would expect it
yeah um when do you think we'll be on
mars
i think moon is i mean certainly this
decade we're going to see a return to
the moon which is incredibly exciting
mars i think is next decade the 2030s is
the focus on mars
it's interesting isn't it that we've not
been to the moon for such a long time
and and in fact only 12 men no women
were ever uh landed on the moon
it is absolutely and this goes back a
little bit to the you know what we were
talking about commercialization of space
because you know space is very difficult
to get to it's expensive and so budgets
are much much smaller than they were in
the apollo era and what we're doing on
the international space station is a
international collaboration many member
states doing that and so by opening up
low earth orbit to commercial companies
it's freeing up the space agencies to be
able to have the resources to go further
afield and to go back to the moon that's
why we haven't been back to the moon you
know for so long so so this is why it's
really exciting that we're now in this
phase where
you know europe is very much part of
this effort of returning to the moon by
the mid 2020s